Dominique Leblanc bonjour Merci d'être
au coulisses du pouvoir mais bon matin
monsieur Thibault c'est le blanc tout le
monde a l'air de vouloir la tenue d'une
enquête publique sauf vous pourquoi
écoutez nous avons été très transparent
depuis plusieurs années quand on menace
de l'ingérence étrangère dans le
contexte électoral nous avons pris à
plus nous avons mis en place plusieurs
mesures pour combattre ces menaces
quelque chose que les conservateurs ont
jamais fait quand ils étaient au
gouvernement pour une dizaine d'années
avant 2015 nous avons témoigné devant
des comités parlementaires nous avons
créé un comité de parlementaire de tous
les partis politiques qui peuvent
recevoir des renseignements à top secret
très privilégié alors nous avons déjà
mais c'est Thibault énormément de
mesures en place pour s'assurer que nous
avons
poursuivi toutes les pistes nécessaires
pour contrer ces
à quel point est-ce que à quel moment
qui a su quoi à quel moment est-ce que
ça aurait pu avoir les gens on entend
ces demandes d'enquête publique pourquoi
c'est pas un forum ecoutez moi j'étais
député d'opposition aussi c'est facile
de réclamer toutes sortes d'affaires
c'est sûr que monsieur Harper a jamais
mené un gouvernement aussi secret dans
l'histoire du Canada nous avons comme
ministre comme gouvernement accepté de
témoigner dans les forums publics les
comités parlementaires la semaine passée
nous avons vu des responsables des
agences de sécurité ceux et celles qui
ont siégé sur le panel que nous avons
mis sur pied en 2019 et 2021 précisément
pour surveiller les menaces d'ingérence
étrangères dire qu'il y avait pas de
menace qui a fait en sorte ou pas
d'ingérence qui a fait en sorte que les
élections n'étaient pas libre et
démocratique nous allons témoigner
communiste devant le comité
parlementaire mais monsieur Thibault le
comité de député conservateur libéraux
du bloc des sénateurs qui sont aptes à
recevoir des renseignements des agences
de sécurité ont précisément le mandat
d'enquêter sur ce genre de question ils
ont le libre champ de décider eux-mêmes
comment procéder alors il y a énormément
énormément d'institutions qui sont en
place qui font leur travail et qui ont
assuré que les élections étaient libres
et démocrates donc dans le passé donc
une enquête publique ça donnerait rien
de plus essentiellement c'est ce que
vous dites mais vous avez entendu ou
même la semaine passée les responsables
des agences de renseignements le
sous-maintre des Affaires étrangères
d'autres experts non partisans dire que
c'est pas un forum qui va nécessairement
amené d'autres précisions il y a déjà en
place des
institutions des comités non partisans
de haut fonctionnaires et de
parlementaires qui peuvent regarder ces
questions là et malgré tout le bruit des
parties d'opposition ces responsables
non partisans en confirmé que les
élections dans 338 circonscriptions ont
été décidées par des Canadiens d'une
façon libre et démocratique c'est quoi
la solution alors parce que ça semble
pas être suffisant pour bien des
Canadiens je regarde un sondages la
semaine dernière qui disait qu'il y a un
quart des Canadiens qui pensent que
l'élection a été volée il y a des gens
qui commencent à entretenir ce genre de
il y a peut-être un déficit de confiance
envers l'institution démocratique
comment vous faites pour gérer ça mais
nous faisons qu'est-ce que nous avons
fait depuis que nous avons formé le
gouvernement en 2015 on a mis sur pied
on a changé la loi premièrement pour
renforcer des mesures pour contrer
l'ingérence étrangère qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement conservateur précédent a
pas fait nous avons mis sur pied un de
haut fonctionnaires
monsieur Leblanc il y a eu de la gérance
et c'est ça que le rapport a dit cette
semaine alors vous faites pas nouveau
l'ingérence ou des des tentatives
d'ingérence et pas nouveau ça existait
dans les années de Monsieur herper le
gouvernement Harper a rien fait nous
avons mis sur pied comme j'ai dit des
mesures que les eaux fonctionnaires la
semaine passée ont confirmé était
robuste et qui ont constaté qu'il n'y a
pas eu d'ingérence qui a fait en sorte
que le résultat dans aucune
circonscription aurait été différente
alors nous allons continuer de renforcer
dans le mesure du possible tout ce que
nous pouvons faire pour contrer cette
ingérence c'est pas seulement au Canada
et c'est pas seulement depuis quelques
années mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les mesures sont en place qui ont été
efficaces est-ce que les Canadiens
devraient savoir quand cette tentative
d'ingérence parce que ça a été le cas
dans l'élection 2021 on le sait
maintenant on ne le SAP on ne l'a pas su
durant la campagne est-ce que Canadiens
devraient savoir presque en temps réel
est-ce qu'on devrait les avertir quand
tu as des tentatives ne serait-ce que
pour maintenir un certain niveau de
confiance envers le système démocratique
mais vous avez entendu le sous-ministre
des Affaires étrangères la semaine
passée maintenir la confiance des
Canadiens ne passe pas par rendre public
des renseignements qui sont peut-être
pas fiables qui sont hors contexte vous
savez les agences de sécurité nationale
sont au travail ils font un travail
important et robuste dans ce domaine ici
mais chaque fois qu'il y a un
renseignement qui arrive à quelqu'un
spécialisé dans le domaine
d'alerter le public avant qu'on ait une
façon de confirmer la fiabilité et
l'ampleur de ce renseignement fera en
effet l'opposé ça va créer une
inquiétude possiblement où il y a pas
raison de d'inquiéter en termes de
l'impact de ce tentative d'ingérer c'est
pas nouveau ceci monsieur Thibault c'est
pas uniquement la Chine qui le fait
c'est
pas uniquement au Canada il y a ces
tentatives-là est-ce que ça a été une
bonne semaine pour votre gouvernement la
semaine passée parce que vu de
l'extérieur on a l'impression que ça a
été une semaine difficile pour vous ce
que c'est une bonne semaine mais écoutez
au gouvernement il y a des fois des
semaines qui sont plus difficiles que
d'autres moi ça fait longtemps que je
suis député à la Chambre des communes
j'ai vu des semaines très agréable et
j'ai vu des semaines plus difficiles
dans le gouvernement de Monsieur
chrétien Monsieur Martin monsieur Harper
et nous avons eu comme gouvernement des
semaines difficiles aussi mais le fond
de la ferme mais c'est Thibault moi je
suis très serein que nous avons comme
gouvernement agit d'une façon robuste
nous avons mis sur pied des mesures qui
existaient dans aucun gouvernement
précédent les mesures pour contrer
l'ingérence en fonctionné on va
continuer de faire notre travail pour
renforcer la protection des institutions
démocratiques mais je partage pas l'idée
qui a eu une ingérence au Canada qui a
pas été contrée par des mesures Rob
ustes et qui a fait en sorte que
l'élection a pas été complètement libre
et démocratique Dominique Leblanc
ministre des Affaires
intergouvernementales aussi responsable
des institutions démocratiques merci
d'avoir été une autre c'est moi qui vous
remercie bonne journée